[MUSIC PLAYING]
RYAN MATSUMOTO: Welcome
to the quick start
tutorial for Workflows.
In this video,
we're going to walk
through how to get started with
Workflows, which allows you
to create serverless workflows
that reliably perform
a series of related tasks
in an order you define.
To start, make sure you have
a Google Cloud project set up
in the Google Cloud Platform
Console with billing enabled.
You can either
create a new project
or use an existing project.
Next, enable the Workflows API.
In the navigation menu,
click on APIs & Services.
Click the Enable APIs and
Services button at the top.
Search for workflows and
select it from the results.
On the Workflows API
page, click Enable
to enable it for the project.
Setup a service account
to grant permissions
needed by your workflow
to call services.
In the navigation menu, click on
IAM & Admin, Service Accounts.
Click Create Service
Account at the top.
Give your service account
a name and click Create.
Give your service account the
role of Logging, Logs Writer.
Click Continue and then Done.
Navigate to the Workflows
page in the Cloud Console.
It will be one of the
options in the Tools section.
On the Workflows
page, click Create.
Provide a name for the workflow,
such as myFirstWorkflow.
Select us-central1 for the
region, and select the service
account you created earlier
for Service account.
Click Next.
In the Workflow
Editor, we're going
to use the example workflow.
This workflow fetches
the current date and time
from a deployed Cloud Function.
It then takes the
current day of the week
and sends it to
the Wikipedia API
to fetch relevant articles on
Wikipedia about the current day
of the week.
Click Deploy.
Now that your workflow has
been successfully deployed,
you can go ahead
and test it out.
After deploying
the workflow, you
are brought to its Details page.
Click the Execute button at the
top, and then click Execute.
This will execute
your new workflow
and print out the final
results at the bottom.
You can see that some
Wikipedia articles related
to today's day of the week
include Thursday Night Football
and Thursday afternoon.
As you can see, Workflows
allows you to connect APIs
with serverless computing.
You can also use Workflows to
connect custom services built
on products like Cloud Functions
and Cloud Run, GCP services,
such as Cloud Firestore, and any
APIs available on the internet.
And that's it.
Congratulations on creating,
deploying, and executing
your first workflow.
Make sure to check out the rest
of our Workflows documentation
to learn more.
[MUSIC PLAYING]